let's do a little more on politics
though because you consider yourself a
libertarian correct sort of yes I'm more
of an issues guy but I've leaned
libertarian most of my life since
college yeah and but I've changed mine
on certain issues that libertarians are
not too happy about and then the reason
I'm avoid using the term so much now is
because a pigeon pigeon holds you into a
category in which yours and then it
makes it more like a religion like okay
so libertarian so you can't believe in
any gun controls right it's like well no
actually I think maybe background checks
are a good idea and you know magazine
clips should be a certain you know it's
just a few things you know it's like
you've abandoned us right you know like
what are we a try right it's like Orion
or your Republican name only your Libra
your align ours yeah exactly
right yeah these are these are the
points you have to hold to all of them
or else you're not in our tribe yeah
okay so well maybe I don't want to be in
the tribe maybe I just want to look at
issues in what I like about the
libertarians is I don't like either the
far right or for our left and so it sort
of pushes toward the more in the middle
I guess the spectrum the problem of the
spectrum is that it's not really a
spectrum like that you know there's
other places you could be you know more
of a you know pure diamond shape but
nevertheless that and things like
climate change you know it's like we're
supposed to be against believing in
climate change because we're
pro-capitalist it's like wait eater it's
getting warmer it's not this is just an
empirical question it has nothing to do
with politics yeah does that show you
that's a good example of how politics
and religion and just rationality and
irrationally it all gets mucked up so I
hear you because a lot of people you
know I've always considered myself a
liberal and now I see I get emails and
tweets every day people going Dave's on
his way to becoming a libertarian
because I will always stand up for
liberty and I believe that the
individual person ultimately I think you
could you know for gay marriage for
example well I can defend it from a
liberal point of view because I think
people should be allowed to marry who
they want it's also very easily defended
by a libertarian point right or Medical
Marijuana or things like that so that's
a place where I
that I think classic liberals and
libertarians can sort of come together
and I do think that that concept is sort
of where politics should go in general
absolutely I mean dr. King made the
point about gay marriage back when you
know people say well you shouldn't get
involved in that back in the 60s and you
know and he said no our freedom is
wrapped up in their freedom you know if
you can suppress somebody because of
this particular way that they are then
you can suppress them for other category
we will just freedom across the board
and that's right that's the principle
yeah so is that idea though really
what's so dangerous about identity
politics because it's not what dr. King
said that we have to protect everybody
else it's actually identity politics
like we got to protect ourselves and
then you know what happens everyone else
is sort of second and exactly it's just
tribalism it's just you know this is our
tribe these are what the things we
believe even like the humanism when I
got involved in the whole skeptics
movement in the late 80s early 90s well
I'm a humanist and then I you know I
started reading the humanist magazines
and conferences but I could clearly see
they had a list of talking points that
were just just clearly right down the
straight political left there's like
well what about these things over here
you know all those the evil Republicans
evil conservatives like wait a minute
wait a minute
I thought you're a humanist just science
reason you stay out of politics but
again we're just for political animals
you know we just want to be tribal and
so you know libertarians you know it's
like herding cats you know we're never
gonna be a big party so I'm not even
sure it's a worthwhile label yeah I'd
love to figure out a way to sort of get
those principles out there more even
though I don't need as you know as I
just said I don't need the label for
myself but I think you can make a lot of
strong moral arguments not using
religion yes through the libertarian
lens language matters so you know maybe
word fit we're in favor of liberty and
freedom aren't you in favor of liberty
and freedom instead of gun control gun
safety mm-hmm I believe in gun safety I
think people should be trained if they
have a gun I think they should keep
their gun locked up safely don't you
agree you know anyone in the NRA should
go well yes of course that's what our
organization is gun safety that's why
they were founded yeah but control makes
it sound like you're trying to control
my freedom you
control my individuality and that feels
wrong you know so the language does
matter I think how we use these things
so the gun arguments kind of interesting
because I think there is a certain
element of conspiracy theory with the
people the people that are totally
pro-gun to the point that you should be
allowed to have whatever it is you want
and that one day you're gonna have to
rise up and fight the government and all
that you know I've said on the show many
times like I get it we left England you
know because we didn't want to live
under a king in a tyrannical government
and no taxation there was a date and all
that stuff but there's an element of
conspiracy to that that the government
is coming to get these people yes right
so the more that the government tries to
get their guns the more they want their
guns right so it doesn't that becomes a
cycle so how do we break that Obama has
sold more guns I mean they say that
constant how do we break that cycle well
I think I think we need to get to
organizations like the NRA and say you
you've gone down the wrong path you know
you really should be in favor of safety
and these are the kinds of things we
need to have background checks I mean
just change the conversation so so
you're in favor of like a terrorist
getting guns for free and killing people
in America you think that that should be
well no no no they should be - well how
can you tell if they're a terrorist or
not I mean we just have to have
background checks for everybody they're
not gonna tell you at the border yeah
I'm coming here to kill Americans you
know so you know you need the general
principles there and what about you know
erudite anybody fly an airplane well no
they they should be licensed of course
they should be licensed so I try try to
use those arguments and also take the
approach like I do with with Christians
you know I used to be one I used to be a
Christian you were a Christian yeah what
happened okay
so then at least they're listening you
know I used to be against all gun
control you know I had guns I grew up
with guns I had a I had a handgun in my
home for 20 years you know I'm but you
know I got a change of mind you changed
your mind I started reading and thinking
about it look at these studies and so on
and so to open the door to a
conversation but guns are almost Tellez
Matic now yeah they're almost like
religious icons representing freedom and
liberty and God and Jesus I don't know
it's all wrapped up in a package now
yeah that people just lose their minds
when you talk about it so as long as
we're talking guns let's knock out a
couple other just
hot-button political things and see if
we can figure out the moral argument for
them before we wrap up so something like
abortion which as a general rule I'm for
the woman being able to make decisions
about her body but at the same point I
would understand that having an abortion
at eight months or seven months or even
six months in my opinion you're
definitely destroying yes a human life
now if your people don't want to have
that conversation right people are
afraid to have that conversation so what
what moral argument can you make that is
for I assume you I'm guessing you're for
abortion I'm pro-choice so you are
portrayed so what's your abortion yeah
okay so that's why language matters yeah
but what moral argument can you make
that's for abortion that also
understands that at some point before
that thing is the woman's body it is a
life right at the same point well I
think the law has tracked this fairly
closely to our intuitions that you know
a third trimester abortion is it is
wrong you know the gray area in the
second trimester no gray area and the
first trimester kind of tracking our
sense about whether it's an individual
or not is it a person that's you know
thinking cognizant can feel and suffer
and and so there I think you can make
the case I try to in the moral arc that
that that the freedom of adult women to
have control and choice over their own
bodies slightly Trump's the rights or
whatever of the fetus just barely
I'm not pro-abortion I am pro-choice and
it would be better if you know if the
numbers got down but if but on that if
it's our goal to decrease the number of
abortions the best thing you can do is
get women educated prosperous and access
to birth control and the numbers just go
down right that's that's where we really
fail as a society right because the same
people that don't want abortions also
cut sex education right and then it's
like what you know and then they cut
social services so people feel like if
they're gonna have a kid and not have
money for it well they don't want that
kid so it's like again it's another one
of these never and
cycles and the other argument I make and
the moral arc is a historical and that
his historically men have always lorded
it over women particularly about sex and
paternity and so on and just if you just
look at the history of marriage in the
history of men and women's relationships
for thousands of years it's always men
trying to control women and there's good
evolutionary reasons for this Pinker
argues about this in the blank slate you
know a whole chapter on sex and all that
stuff and you know men are obsessed with
controlling women's sexuality and this
is one of the big things that have
helped the women's movement is to is to
break that those chains and give women
the freedom so that's my final argument
is that in addition to you know the
rights of the fetus so on all those but
but just in the long run it's better to
give women more freedom than less and
and to keep men out of that area of
control yeah so that sounds like it
would line up with some libertarian
values absolutely the Liberty so most
libertarians are pro-choice for sure
yeah so there's a few like Ron Paul
who's sort of considered itself a
libertarian but he's Christian Right see
there you see that interesting conflict
also he was also a gynecologist you know
there's so again libertarians are all
over the board you know there's there's
plenty of atheist libertarians but
there's plenty of believers are just in
the middle they're not religious at all
and and they're also very much split on
foreign policy you know should we be
isolationist Sarge do we need to go help
people that need help you know so well
like a like a Rand Paul you very
isolation this is father even more so
mm-hmm so I I get those arguments but on
the other hand don't we have a moral
obligation to help people whose own
freedoms and liberties are being
oppressed by tyrannical dictators yes we
do yeah okay so and this is what that
split in the left they were talking
about earlier really hugely about what
can we do and are we imposing our values
and all that but let's just do one more
and then we got to wrap up so I want to
talk about a moral argument you can make
on the economic level I think is really
interesting you know when you hear
people talking about well Bernie wants
to tax everybody at ninety percent we
know it's not ninety percent it's a
progressive tax so it's not you know
without getting into too much into the
numbers there but it's not really taxing
you at 90% it progressively increases
versus a flat tax can you make a moral
argument for economics that makes sense
I'm not sure absolutely across the board
but but the idea of running different
experiments for say different states in
the 50 states have different tax systems
and you can kind of look at the outcome
of what happens
socially in that and economically in
that particular state you know does it
become more or less prosperous with the
progressive tax versus a flat tax I
would actually like to see some states
just do have straight flat tax and just
see what happens yeah or maybe try it
for a while you know maybe maybe we
should abolish the IRS do a straight
sixteen and a half percent whatever it
was I think the Cruz wants that right so
it's right let's see what happens
you know run the experiment and we can
always go back you know so I'm in favor
of just trying different things and a
lot of those things I'm not sure that
there's an absolute single answer here I
like Sam's metaphor of the multiple
peaks on the moral landscape so how do
we decide which peak is right you can't
there is no there's no right peak right
right for you so this is kind of a
libertarian argument you know you want
to paint your house red with a purple
door fine but in our neighborhood we
don't like the houses that look like
that they all look the same that's
that's what we like in this neighborhood
but that neighborhood over there
make it Topanga right where everybody
has these wild hippie homes okay fine
yeah so you have different you know
communities that live different ways and
you know I don't like the argument well
just if you don't like America didn't
leave go to Mexico you know come on my
friends are here my family's here my
kids are gonna come on let's see if we
can do local politics and just run
different experiments yeah and often if
you're complaining about it the most it
means you care the most so yes well
hopefully yeah
well listen I could have done this for
another three hours so you're definitely
gonna have to come back because I barely
got to any of the stuff okay my note
cards so I thank you and I want to thank
Michael Shermer for joining me and you
can check out his work at skeptic calm
and at Michael Shermer comm correct all
right there you go we'll do it again
next week thanks